prince charles had other things on his
mind as he arrived to take over the
patronage of the royal college of
surgeons of edinburgh from prince philip
but other matters were waiting
is it appropriate to accept
millions of packs for your charity sir
unsurprisingly left unanswered but the
issue of him being given millions in
cash for his charity by sheikh hamad bin
jassim is one that a senior palace
source had confronted earlier the prince
of wales operates on advice situations
contexts change over the years for more
than half a decade with the situation as
it's evolved this has not happened and
it would not happen again that is then
and this is now
i mean did charles say to the qatari
thank you very much or did he say where
on earth do you get all that cash from i
mean it is so astonishing
that the heir to the throne
should be even putting himself in that
position so
when the palace says that was then that
was now that's nonsense
what happened then is very relevant to
what happens now and his charles's whole
status
as the future king over the weekend it
was reported that the former qatari
prime minister had handed him three
million euros between 2011 and
2015. on one occasion in a suitcase on
another cache which was reportedly put
into fortnum mason carrier bags claret's
house it was immediately handed to his
charity and they carried out all the
appropriate checks
the charity commission are reviewing if
they should investigate there is no
suggestion that anything illegal has
taken place
it's unusual for cash donations of that
size to be given and received these days
things will be done by bank transfer
in a way that is
visible to the charity visible to the
donor and enables the charity to account
for what they
receive in a very transparent way later
on
as the met police are investigating
another of the prince's charities over
cash for access claims something the
palace say he had no knowledge of this
is another difficult matter as all
efforts are being made to reinforce his
credentials as a future king
rhiannon mills sky news